North Las Vegas Police are investigating
a crash involving four cars on carry
near Las Vegas Boulevard officers say
two cars they believe were racing ran
through a four-way stop then crashed
into two other cars one of those cars
then ricocheted and hit a child killing
her 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough spoke with the victim's family
tonight she joins us with our top story
[Music]
yeah twelve-year-old Yelina tarango's
vigil was held tonight as friends and
family gathered lying down candles and
fresh flowers as you can see there her
mother Veronica who did not want to show
her face on camera speaking exclusively
to 8 news now about the crash
and I want Justice for my daughter this
is not right what they did Veronica
Carrillo and shambles after losing her
youngest child Yelina in a hit-and-run
crash Tuesday
it's all happening just after 3 30 p.m
on Tuesday in broad daylight the driver
who hit and killed Galena took off
running and has yet to be found has been
very devastating because a lot of
questions like did you even stop to see
if she was okay did you even try to go
see if there was any way you could save
her other parents noting how dangerous
this long stretch of road is at the
intersection of Kerry and Belmont it's a
35 35 an hour speed limit here on this
street and there are always cars
speeding all the time the kids are
always walking and cars are always
speeding and just not paying attention
North Las Vegas Police confirming that
they have arrested another driver
involved in the crash that driver 19
year old Alfredo Cabrera he is now
facing felony charges of reckless
driving resulting in death reporting
here in North Las Vegas Madison
Kimbrough 8 news now the family has set
up a GoFundMe to cover some expenses we
have that information on our website
8nowsnow.com